[Music]
all right here it is the moment you have
all been waiting for
is our jeopardy warm up tonight we get
to see which of the three contestants
of our three are the most intelligent
for 24 hours and we have got
brian airball loftus we have got
downtown
david charns and we have ted
moneyball florentino i like it yeah i
didn't know about
putting stuff up before you'll get it
all right here's our clue let's play uh
jeopardy warm up
this was the first place in clark county
to be listed on the national register of
historic places back in 1972 you got 15
seconds to start right now two options
here go by the way it was the only this
is the only u.s
state park located
in the city that houses the building
that was first built in that city let's
focus
go and time is up let's start with you
oh look at david still writing stuff
down after we say hey there's rules to
this baby
let's go ahead this is his first one all
right go ahead david you got revealed
all right so i said
what is i'm newish i don't know
i've only been here eight months yeah
how about you i like that i like that
how about who
brian loftus what is
the old mormon fort and if you look
right here you are right brian look over
here look to your left
look to your left right hey ted florendo
how about you all right i thought
springs preserved but
we know the old morning jasmine
older yes congratulations to at least
two of you
sorry um david you'll get it by the way
that was the midway point
that was the midway point between la and
salt lake city a little spring there
they built to fort as we mentioned
the only u.s state park in america that
has the first building
in the first uh the first house building
inside this city yeah
still still standing all right hey we
are yeah whatever
we're out of time hey thanks for
watching us here on eight news now at 6
30 we are always on come on over we're
always on
our well too late guys oh